friend in the kitchen his name was etchy
and he was like a blood and one day he
came up to me he's like hey bro you got
to help me out I'm like what's up
because
my freezes are slipping well
my freezes look you got to help me out
I'm like what are you talking about what
cause I breathe he goes a freeze when
you don't practice it people could tell
the difference in your voice when you
don't practice saying freeze when you're
gonna rob somebody here we go again
we're coming to the dining area please
people go don't report me I just want to
try it he goes my brother got out of
jail then practice is freezing he got
locked up a week later
his preachers didn't have no confidence
behind